hey there by Muse just a quick one this
time I'm visiting my family in
Bournemouth this weekend so I didn't
have time to film a full length video as
usual however as I'm trying to be
consistent now of my YouTube uploading
and I didn't want to leave you hanging I
thought I'd go back through some of my
archive footage from videos past and
pick out my favorite and most unique
exercises either that I've invented
myself or that I've found Elsewhere on
my travels across the web hopefully this
will keep you busy you can try some of
these workouts yourself maybe they'll
inspire you to come to some of your own
unique exercises and next time I'll have
something a bit longer for you to check
out so until then have a good one and
enjoy these
thank you
foreign